russisch unterricht am hamburger
christianeum gymnasium an diesem tag auf
dem stundenplan
russische zahlen bis 100 um die zu
lernen so der lehrer sei es wichtig sie
häufig zu wiederholen aber gleich ein
ganzes schuljahr wiederholen das wird in
dieser achten klasse niemand mehr
denn das sitzenbleiben wurde in hamburg
weitgehend abgeschafft
für die meisten schüler keineswegs ein
grund zum jubeln
am ende des jahres und man verliert dann
hat auch den anschluss wenn jetzt nur
die guten immer mit krach mit dem stoff
mit und die schlechten immer nur um den
stören die auch weil die nicht mitkommen
weil die nicht beteiligen können
die möglichkeit dass man sitzen bleiben
kann ist ein ziemlicher ansporn für für
die meisten leute dass sie denken okay
ich muss ich muss ich muss ihm halt
nicht dass ich sitzen bleibe bundesweit
beträgt die sitzenbleiberquote etwa zwei
prozent im vergangenen schuljahr mussten
rund 160.000 schüler eine klasse
wiederholen
viele bildungsexperten halten das
sitzenbleiben für pädagogisch sinnlos
immer mehr bundesländer wollen die
sogenannten ehrenrunden jetzt abschaffen
es ist so dass ein schüler in der regel
wegen weniger fächer sitzen bleibt aber
muss ein jahr lang sämtliche fächer noch
einmal machen
auch sport und auch musik und auch
englisch vielleicht nur weil er in
physik und mathematik große probleme
hatte und deswegen ist es viel besser
gezielt an dieser stelle zu fördern und
den schüler hier weiter zu bringen und
nicht die ganze palette noch einmal
durch zu nudeln ganz bildungs
deutschland streitet nun über sinn oder
unsinn des sitzenbleibens
oft sitzen gegner und befürworter im
gleichen kollegium der lehrer dieser
achten klasse hält das sitzenbleiben für
falsch erstmals werden die leute die
schüler herausgerissen aus ihrem
sozialen umfeld finde ich nicht in
ordnung kommen eine andere klasse andere
altersgruppe und gerade so im bereich
der mittelstufe macht ein jahr schon
ganz schön viel aus also auch in der
entwicklung persönlichkeitsentwicklung
der schüler
und da fühle ich das eher
kontraproduktiv da sitzen beim was wir
aber an befürchtungen haben ist dass
durch das dass schüler jetzt nicht mehr
sitzen bleiben können sie das als
hängematte empfinden und dann in klasse
zehn
das böse erwachen kommt wenn sie dann
den mittleren abschluss hier eine schule
machen müssen
und das so die schulleiterin könne dann
auch dazu führen dass das niveau von
abschlussprüfungen sinke
denn schließlich wolle keine schule hohe
durchfallquoten in hamburg wurden die
ehrenrunden bisher nur in den klassen
eins bis neun abgeschafft alle älteren
schüler sowie diese zehnklässler können
immer noch sitzen bleiben alex macht die
zehnte bereits zum zweiten mal und das
so meint er sei auch ganz gut so
jetzt wiederhole ich halt und meine und
haben sich wirklich verbessert also und
es geht auch um stoffen oder weniger mit
aber ich hab' ich beteilige mich
vielleicht auch etwas mehr fällt von
selbst in den unteren jahrgangsstufen
aber ist das sitzenbleiben ganz
abgeschafft
wer hier zu schlechte noten hat muss
jetzt einen förderunterricht besuchen
nur sei der im vollen tagesprogramm der
schüler oft kaum noch unterzubringen so
die schulleiterin
schüler in der mittelstufe haben sehr
viel unterricht 34 bis 36 stunden hier
bei uns am gymnasium und zusätzlicher
förderunterricht bedeutet zusätzliche
zeit hier an der schule und irgendwo
müssen die schüler natürlich auch noch
ein bisschen raum für freizeit bekommen
schüler die sitzenbleiben kosten den
steuerzahler pro jahr insgesamt rund 800
millionen euro
denn je mehr schüler im system desto
höher die personalausgaben
auch deshalb wollen viele bundesländer
das sitzenbleiben abschaffen
hamburg sagt ja sie würden jetzt sehr
viel geld investieren in diesen
förderunterricht das mag auch sein dass
jetzt in den ersten jahren investiert
werden muss und diese gelder kommen den
schulen ja auch zugute
aber letztendlich ist es natürlich ein
sparmodell
denn für wirklich qualifizierten
förderunterricht welche das zusätzliche
geld nicht kritisieren elternvertreter
zum beispiel wird jetzt der
nachhilfeunterricht von
oberstufenschülern von pensionierten
lehrern von nachhilfelehrern gemacht
aber nicht von den lehrern die wirklich
wissen vor die lücken der kinder sind
und das gezielt nach arbeiten könnten
ist sitzenbleiben nun also sinnvoll weil
es schlechten schülern eine zweite
chance bietet oder wird bei der
wiederholung einer ganzen klasse nur
wertvolle lebenszeit verplempert
vielleicht hilft ihr ein blick über die
grenzen europas beste schüler kommen aus
finnland
dort ist das sitzenbleiben längst
abgeschafft